[Musica]
almeno una volta nella vita ci siano
emozionanti osservando un'opera d'arte
sia essa una scultura di michelangelo
dipinto che susan oppure ascoltando il
recco intimo o ancora entrando in un
edificio maestoso come la sagrada
famiglia
ma quali sono i processi cerebrali che
ci permettono di vivere davanti all'arte
emozioni è stato e stati d'animo così
molteplici generati no in modo
imprevedibile e inspiegabile questa è la
domanda alla quale una giovane brandt e
delle neuroscienze
la neuroestetica cerca di dare una
risposta a differenza della maggior
parte degli scienziati che sono
impegnati nello studio delle basi
fondamentali e processi biologici e
cognitivi per esempio come le cellule n
on aids sul cervello comunicano tra loro
o come comprendiamo linguaggio come
generiamo movimento o manteniamo
equilibrio coloro che si occupano di
neuro estetica si ed entrano in un
territorio alquanto problematico
lo studio devo biologico dell'esperienza
estetica problematico perché da un lato
la bellezza un'esperienza altamente
soggettiva dall'altro perché attraverso
i secoli
questi argomenti sono già stati oggetto
di speculazioni dei filosofi artisti
scrittori e storici dell'arte del caldo
il bel carico di kant hawking tutto per
quale motivo ma studiosi neuroscienze
dovrebbe scegliere di occuparsi di
questi argomenti perché l'arte è una
creazione nostra mente e dunque le sagre
legge studiare l'arte è esperienza
estetica si rivela quindi una sorgente
inestimabile di informazioni per chi
studia organizzazione le funzioni al
cervello
una ventina di anni fa l'incontro contro
il professore semir zeki noto
neurobiologo neurobiologo fisiologo
inglese
cambia il modo in cui tuttora vivo
l'arte
qui vivo la scienza in occasione di una
mia visita la frase che mi portò la tec
modern e mi fermò di fronte una serie di
pick mondo una terra che consisteva in
linee nere ortogonali fra loro su uno
sfondo bianco allora pensare nulla di
che invece se che mi spiego come
l'artista avesse voluto decomporre le
forme complesse
pensiamo ad un volto per esempio the
componendolo costituenti fondamentali e
come in quello per pittorica come in
altri avesse voluto rappresentare il
frutto del suo lavoro la ricerca
dell'essenza di tutte le forme ovvero la
linea retta
ma la cosa perché un intrigo e ciò che
sei e jones e successivamente che la
conclusione artistica cui ha raggiunto
mondo fu poi confermata da il
neurofisiologo quando scoprirono che
effettivamente il nostro cervello e la
percezione delle forme comincia proprio
tra le fontane di me rete come pone
dipinte dall'artista qualche ricerca i
primi dunque mondrian ascom mode con gli
spargimenti aveva scoperto una delle
funzioni di base del nostro cervello ben
prima tenuto scienziate il genere umano
è composta tali ioni di cellule neurali
raggruppati in aria specializzate per
processi cognitivi oppure per processi
percettivi come colori che avevano una
volta comunicano tra loro costituendo
complicato network di aree che
costantemente si influenza fa loro
questa organizzazione prende il nome di
specializzazione
oggi grazie allo sviluppo tecnologico
possiamo utilizzare delle tecniche di
visualizzazione celebrare come la
risonanza magnetica funzionale
ora ma dietro in seconda fila per
visualizzare in tempo reale ad alta
risoluzione ciò che avviene il nostro
cervello quando immaginiamo percepiamo o
compriamo una qualsiasi azione così come
possiamo visualizzare il sistema tre
aree specializzate per cessione è
un'articolazione linguaggio così siamo
stati in grado anche di rilevare il
sistema di aree cerebrali collocate più
o meno dietro agli occhi è che comprende
una corteccia prefrontale mediale
striato che ci permette di provare
l'esperienza estetica
in particolare l'aumento dell'attività
in queste aree per fronte ad un'opera
d'arte è direttamente correlata
l'intensità dell'esperienza estetica
ovvero cresce con l'aumentare della
bellezza percepita mentre decresce
quando osserviamo un oggetto meno bello
o persino tutto ora cosa a causa del
nostro organismo attivazione di queste
aree la loro attività ci dà una
sensazione di benessere psicofisico e
profondo a pagamento perché appartengono
al sistema dopaminergico infatti auto
bambina è un neurotrasmettitore
conosciuto come il of molli dell'euforia
in quanto legata al che c'è reale
motivazione e meccanismi della
ricompensa manca il sonno amore a morire
apprendimento non è una sorpresa dunque
a prendere che recenti ricerche sono
concordi nell'indicare che le attività
artistiche culturali come ad esempio
guardare aspettati d'arte andrà teatro
su un'altra musica o ascoltare della
musica milioni non hanno una salute e di
benessere psicofisico aumentando la
soddisfazione
riducendo i livelli di ansia e
depressione proprio grazie l'influenza
che queste attività non sono tra
cervelli d'altra parte è noto che i
bassi livelli di dopamina possono
causare l'oppressione comportamenti
antisociali e frustrazione per tornare
alla mia esperienza davanti all'invito
di mondo lavatelli posso dire che la
comprensione risorse i mondrian e del
suo valore anche dal punto di vista
scientifico totalmente modificato come
percepisco dei suoi opere d'arte che la
reputo belle e accendono le mie emozioni
molto positive dunque le percezioni e
bellezza può essere imparata ed allenata
la risposta a questa domanda è se
certamente infatti recenti studi che
abbiamo condotto dimostrano che
l'esperienza del bello il conseguente
rilascio di dopamina tra mondo del
benessere e solo in parte predeterminate
dal nostro profilo genetico mentre viene
continuamente ha preso ed influenzata da
fattori inventare come la cultura e
l'educazione
educare è bello dunque genera benessere
dell'individuo
sebbene questa prova empirica supporti
l'idea che l'arte e la bellezza
contribuiscano a salute mentale
la maggior parte dei governi spengono e
loro risorse per pure spedaliere a lungo
termine per i giano modelli terapeutici
standard se i problemi di salute mentale
fossero affrontati abbastanza presto
riconosce l'organizzazione mondiale
della sanità la necessità di costose
cure ospedaliere potrebbe essere
drasticamente ridotta
ciò potrebbe essere realizzato se una
politica di interventi assistenziali
preventivi ed efficaci prendesse
seriamente in considerazione l'influenza
dell'arte su bese psico fisico invece
come si tornato in par occasione gallo
ms dall'unesco e dalla commissione
europea nei periodi di crisi i nostri
policy makers aprono tagli significativi
alla finanziaria
del settore culturale a causa del comune
ma il romeno confinamento dell'arte alla
sfera del meno rilevante e del puro
divertimento al contrario abbiamo
confermato anche scientificamente che la
bellezza salverà il mondo
come scrisse in dostoevskij la bellezza
e l'arte sono quindi la cura la medicina
gratuita per un presente ed un futuro di
benessere grazie
[Musica]